[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à tous dans
ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo
l'émission de la rédaction pour revenir
sur l'actualité départementale de la
semaine voici les titres de ce vendredi
26 janvier plus d'une cinquantaine de
gardiens de prison ont manifesté une
nouvelle fois vendredi matin devant le
centre pénitentiaire de bois d'arcy
malgré des propositions de la ministre
de la justice
les manifestants réclament plus de
moyens pour leur sécurité personnelle
plus de moyens ils en demandent aussi la
colère monte dans les hôpitaux et
notamment au sein des ehpad
notre invité fil rouge pour cette
émission et freddy brunel secrétaire
adjoint de l'union syndicale solidaires
pour les yvelines dans le reste de
l'actualité retour sur la mise en garde
du président du sénat gérard larcher à
propos de la réforme constitutionnelle
voulue par emmanuel macron ou encore à
un séminaire autour de la place de la
république dans les quartiers organisées
par la préfecture des yvelines nom
débute cette émission avec un message de
prévention en lien avec la crue de la
seine
le pic est attendu ce week-end à paris
et pourrait avoir des conséquences
encore dans les yvelines dans le nord du
département précisément route barrée ou
coupure d'électricité pour faire face à
la situation depuis jeudi la préfecture
a activé le centre opérationnel
départemental et rappelle quelques
conseils en cas d'inondation pensez à
couper à gaz et l'électricité
plus d'informations et de précisions sur
vigicrues point gouv.fr ou yvelines
point gouv.fr tout est parti d'une
agression dans une prison du pas de
calais il y à 12 jours la colère gronde
chez les surveillants pénitentiaires
hier le gouvernement a présenté un
protocole de propositions notamment des
équipements en gilet pare-balles armes
portatives la création aussi de 1100
postes et des revalorisations salariales
pour certains syndicats le compte n'y
est pas des blocages ont continué
vendredi matin comme à la maison
de bois d'arcy elle les précisions avec
grigoriy canal et 7 heures ce vendredi
matin sous l'oeil des crs une
cinquantaine de surveillants
pénitentiaires de la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy est en place depuis une
heure pour bloquer l'accès au site
plusieurs syndicats ont rejeté hier les
dernières propositions du ministère de
la justice
ils reconnaissent une avancée sur les
mesures pour la sécurité des agents mais
attendent une meilleure revalorisation
de leur statut est revenu le
gouvernement a pourtant prévu une
enveloppe de 30 millions d'euros pour
augmenter les indemnités salariales
nous on ne lâchera rien on restera
jusqu'à ce qu'on peut rester voilà tout
en gardant cas est menée avec l'état de
la détention ça s'en crée des tensions
sur la détention de mon restera jusqu'à
ce qu'il faut rester à bois d'arcy comme
dans une soixantaine de prisons
françaises encore aujourd'hui les
surveillants sont mobilisés depuis 12
jours et des débrayages qui impacte
directement la vie de la détention
ça impacte totalement puisque à l'heure
actuelle vous avez le service de nuit
qui est mobilisée encore un cas de deux
d'événement particulier sur la détention
mais il ya aucune aucune vie dans la
détention serre que tous les détenus
sont à l'intérieur et nous on n'ouvre
aucune porte et il se passe plus rien
dans la détention la détention et au
paiement après l'arrivée des pompiers
pour éteindre la barricade enflammée les
crs se préparer charge pour déloger les
manifestants regroupés derrière le
portail d'entrée
les forces de police parvienne
finalement à pénétrer dans l'enceinte de
la maison d'arrêt vers 9h30 la
manifestation s'est ensuite poursuivie à
l'intérieur du site
une crise dans les prisons françaises
qui semble s'enliser ce vendredi la
ministre de la justice à nicole
belloubet a appelé les surveillants à
prendre leur responsabilité pour la
sécurité de la société
les personnels pénitentiaires en grève
et bientôt ceux des maisons de retraite
c'est mardi prochain ils dénoncent la
réforme du mode financement des ehpad
faut-il craindre un mouvement à l'instar
des prisons mais cette fois ci dans les
hôpitaux nous allons poser les questions
à notre invité fil rouge freddy brunel
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire
adjoint de l'union syndicale solidaires
pour les yvelines
le personnel médical va-t-il lui aussi
se lancer dans un mouvement de grève
pour dénoncer la politique du
gouvernement en matière de santé un peu
comme ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
les prisons il ya une continuité dans la
politique du gouvernement puisque depuis
bachelot en a plusieurs lois qui
touchent directement la pérennité de
l'hôpital public et y compris les ehpad
un public
la loi bachelot la loi touraine qui a
mis en place les j'ai acheté du
groupement hospitalier de carrie thouars
qui est un regroupement des hôpitaux 1
c'est un peu l'idée mutualisation des
moyens
c'est à dire aussi économique des moyens
et le gouvernement dit que c'est plus
efficace aussi pour l'offre de sources à
cela pour éviter des désastres 2 on en
parlera si vous voulez donc c'est une
économie sur les moyens 16h02 personnel
mais également des structures
il y à un mouvement le 30 janvier d
exploitation les établissements
d'hébergement pour les personnes âgées
et dépendantes dont quitte en parallèle
des maisons de retraite et les ehpad en
fait en deux en deux temps il ya un
secteur lucratif ya également au secteur
public
pratique nous annonce que concrètement
50 millions d'euros pour soutenir les
ehpad
juste pour préciser lucratif vous le
dire il ya un secteur privé au secteur
public et donc 50 millions d'euros qui
seraient alloués
dans les ehpad alors qu'on sait qu'il y
a un manque d'effectifs flagrant que
dans le cadre de la politique qui est
menée par le gouvernement actuel mais
donc c'est une continuité quand je vous
disais il ya une souffrance du personnel
mais aussi d'autres victimes c'est à
dire les patients sains qui ne sont pas
soignés dans les conditions qu'il
faudrait il faut savoir que dans
certains ehpad
on se retrouve à doucher les personnes
une fois tous les quinze jours et qu'une
toilette de dire que divine ne dire que
dix minutes ça c'est de les voir manger
dans un ehpad
c'est ce qu'on vous a raconté ne sais
pas ce qu'on leur raconte et de
témoignages des gens qui travaillent
d'ailleurs hier soir j'étais avec des
gens qui travaillent en d'ehpad et qui
quittant en souffrance au travail
trois victimes il ya aussi le monde
irait ge la famille qui tu dois la
versys de maître lors leurs parents donc
au sein des ehpad
alors maintenant je on va stylia c'est
en nous dit 50 millions d'euros vont
soutenir les ehpad j'espère public dans
un premier temps et dans un deuxième
temps c'est faire un parallèle sur les
yvelines
vous mettez les 50 millions d'euros qui
sera donné par l'ensemble des états par
rapport au financement d'un seul
bâtiment sur poissy qui sont les
urgences qu'on attendait depuis des
années soixante et onze méo d'euros
faite par les cinq ans il est très
rapide c'est très peu juste qu'ils ont
vu que vous êtes ici tout seul en
plateau on va donner la parole à agnès
buzyn ce qu'elle était en déplacement ce
matin dans les yvelines vendredi matin
dans l'est dans les yvelines elle a
évoqué ce sujet des ehpad je vous
propose de l'écouter c'était au micro de
nicolas dandois nous avons d'ores et
déjà voté une augmentation de budget de
100 millions d'euros pour les ehpad pour
augmenter les professionnels en fonction
de la charge en soins pour créer des
postes d'infirmières de nuit et je viens
de proposer un fléchage de 50 millions
d'euros aux agences régionales de santé
pour qu'elle puisse accompagner les
équipes les ehpad les plus en
difficultés qui pourraient se sentir
perdants de la réforme tarifaire je veux
qu'à l'arrivée il n'y ait aucun perdant
parce que les besoins sont immenses dans
les ehpad et mon engagement
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de
réductions de postes où que ce soit donc
agnès buzyn était ce vendredi matin à
chevreuse dans les yvelines
elle dit en gros qu'il n'y a pas de
suppressions pas de quoi s'inquiéter que
l'état est là pour soutenir les ehpad
qui seront en difficulté vous vous dites
que ça c'est de la communication en gros
c'est la communication
la politique du gouvernement donc
actuelle soutient ce qui a été fait
l'année passée
l'année passée en a économisé 850
millions d'euros sur la masse salariale
de l'ensemble des hôpitaux publics cela
correspond à une baisse de 22 mille
postes au sein de l'hôpital public et
madame busan dans la continuité
notamment en votant faisant voter donc
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale 2 mais des grèves encore les
hôpitaux publics et dans les hôpitaux
publics on y retrouve les ehpad publics
aussi un s'il faut donner un exemple
concret par exemple à poissy vous avez
deux ehpad publics 1 qui qui sont
assujettis à l'hôpital public de
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye est là pour
le coup quand on baisse de 1,4 milliard
2,6 milliards d'euros qui réclamait pour
les hôpitaux publics en 2018 c'est même
un peu plus je dirais qu'il est vrai non
mais attendez on prend du retard en a
perdu 22 mille postes l'année passée ont
des grèves encore donc les hôpitaux
publics d'autant milliards on va se
retrouver avec une pénurie de personnel
qui sera de boubaux de plus en plus
prégnant là il ya urgence
quel est le risque concrètement c'est à
dire que jours les médecins auraient pu
faire leur boulot des burnout
l exemple concret j'en ai parlé hier
avec une infirmière du bloc opératoire
dont à poissy saint germain en laye qui
me disait que mercredi soir on a fermé
le bloc opératoire puisqu'on n'avait pas
l'ensemble du personnel pour pouvoir
tenir le bloc opératoire de manière
sécurisée
voyez un peu les problématiques qu'on a
vous rappellerai pas les temps
d'attentes que ce soit au niveau des
urgences
je vous rappellerai pas non plus que
pour pouvoir soigner un certain nombre
de malades
il faut un certain nombre de soignants
de personnel soignant
quand on sait que je vous donne
l'exemple de
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye parce que
je connais bien
quand on des grèves de 150 personnes qui
travaillent dans camp par un but d'écart
et que ça soit infirmiers aides
soignants secrétaire et compagnie tout
ce qui est logistique au sein de
l'hôpital on se retrouve avec des
problématiques pour pouvoir soigner dans
les meilleures conditions possibles les
patients on se retrouve dans une
situation de maltraitance et du coup ma
question qu'elle était allée se poser
maintenant c'était celle de l'image du
système de santé en france on a toujours
une image en tout cas l'international
parfois d'un système très avancé très
égalitaire très très social est ce que
cette image aujourd'hui avec les
politiques qui sont qui sont mises en
place
ce fossé faut cesser plus le cas
aujourd'hui en france qu'on a pu ce
système tend parfois souhaité par par
nos voisins européens ou internationaux
et grâce à qui on a toujours un système
de santé à la pointe des traces au
personnel qui a une conscience
professionnelle à goody tire encore un
bon système utilise un système qui est
qui est très performant le problème
quand je vous le dis farhat et pressuré
le monde médical
sur quoi on fait l'économie encore
aujourd'hui le gouvernement
le gouvernement fait l'économie sur son
personnel c'est à dire que le fait de
rappeler le personnel soignant chez eux
sont en congé ou autres quand il manque
du personnel
cela fait économiser cinq milliards
d'euros sur le budget au lieu
d'embaucher
je veux dire ils feraient mieux
d'investir cet argent là pour embaucher
du monde est là la problématique c'est
pas un milieu où en forme des gens du
jour au lendemain ça suffit de parler du
numerus clausus des médecins des années
pour former un médecin c'est ça comme
c'est quoi
changer là à quoi tenait déjà on arrête
de des gréves et le budget comme cela
fait actuellement en arêtes et là c'est
un appel qui est fait notamment part sud
santé sociaux et l'ensemble des hôpitaux
aux luttes qui se sont réunis tout
récemment ils étaient une quarantaine
d'hôpitaux en lutte 40 hôpitaux en lutte
mais il ya beaucoup plus un qui se sont
réunis ce mois ci et qui vont s'associer
avec le mouvement des ehpad pour
justement dire il faut qu'il y ait un
moratoire sur notamment la loi touraine
qui s'applique avec notamment lé
groupement hospitalier territoire comme
je vous disais qui est une mutualisation
des hôpitaux et là on demande un
moratoire cela s'arrête et qu'on arrête
de supprimer des postes au sein des
hôpitaux il faut absolument moins en
avant une politique d'embauché et de
recrutement à long terme avant de
continuer sur ce sujet peut-être une
précision par rapport à l'hôpital de
poissy saint germain est l'extension
puisque nous avions prouvé à 7 cette
actualité il ya une dizaine de jours et
nous avions fait une erreur en indiquant
que vous étiez contre cette extension ce
qui n'est pas le cas vous vous dénoncez
principalement le manque de moyens vous
dénoncez pas l'extension du site contre
le mans en la réclamer mais le réclame
depuis des années on le réclame depuis
des années depuis le jour où la rs
annoncé qu'on créerait un hôpital donc à
chambourcy reste investi on la perd 2
argent 1 21 million d'euros qui ont été
investis dans du patrimoine terriens à
rien je veux dire on n'a pas fait
d'hôpital et donc depuis en réclame d
urgence donc des locaux neufs donc au
sein de l'hôpital de poissy saint
germain en laye parce qu'il est tout à
fait inadmissible de travailler dans ces
conditions là s'est réclamée par notre
collectif qu'on avait été convenu en
plus à l'époque par notre syndicat sud
santé sociaux et l'union syndicale
solidaires depuis des années on le
réclame le problème il faut être
critique aussi sur le fait que le
financement des hôpitaux des urgences à
poissy en une vraie problématique c'est
à dire que en a été face à une politique
d'économies qui s'appelle le cref le
plan de retour à l'économie c'est à dire
que le financement des urgences à poissy
ce sont ces faits sur le dos
notamment des du personnel puisque
depuis plusieurs années pour revenir à
l'équilibré financier un bourreau n'est
par l'état le pit ld réclamant les sur
le sacrifier andes entre 150 et 200
agents donc paramédicaux au sein de
l'hôpital ce qui fait comme je le disais
des problèmes donc de conditions de
travail qui s'aggrave
la mise au point en moins claires pour
l'hôpital de poissy mea culpa encore une
fois dernière question juste juste une
anecdote d'un la moitié la moitié des
urgences ont été financés par l'état
c'est financé c'est à dire sur les six
étages dans la 3 étages c'est garanti
par contre on n'a toujours pas fait peur
que ça soit fait sur justement c'est à
dire que l'hôpital envisage de se
séparer d'un certain nombre de
patrimoines pour financer ce qu'il
manque un 71 des 11 millions d'euros y
manque la moitié est donc quand je parle
de patrimoine
et quand on parle des ehpad sachez que
son périmètre de poissy-saint-germain là
deux ehpad et on se battra pour garnir
garder ses deux ehpad au sein de
l'hôpital public parce que on considère
que ça ne s'est pas du patrimoine dans
l'hôpital devrait se séparer ni de
l'ensemble du patrimoine dont il dispose
on a d'autres à saint germain en laye on
a bien compris le message merci freddy
brunel d'être venu en plateau répondre à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire adjoint du coup de l'union
syndicale solidaires pour les yvelines
merci encore à vous et bon week-end
on passe maintenant au résumé de
l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
google coca cola facebook ou encore
goldman sachs 140 patrons de
multinationales étaient réunis au
château de versailles lundi pour le
sommet choose france choisira la france
le premier ministre edouard philippe et
le président emmanuel macron présenter
et vanter les évolutions de l'économie
française un événement auquel a
participé le député de la première
circonscription des yvelines député de
la république en marche didier baichère
propos recueillis par nicolas landry
on a parlé beaucoup avec le ceo de bank
of america de financement est également
le patron d'allianz donc nous ont posé
beaucoup de questions sur l'agilité en
france les réformes qu'on envisageait
par rapport à la fiscalité il avait bien
bien entendu les sujets de la flat tax
que j'ai mis en place et on a eu aussi
assez rapidement des questions sur
l'agilité du marché du travail sur notre
capacité à transformer des compétences
des salariés
donc j'avais pu expliquer qu'on allait
mettre 15 milliards sur la table
aujourd'hui pour développer notre
programme de formation professionnelle
et puis pour développer l'apprentissage
qui est une clé en fait du développement
des compétences de demain un début de
rapport de force avec emmanuel macron
notre dit gérard larcher président du
sénat élu du sud yvelines a présenté ses
propositions pour la future réforme
constitutionnelle voulue par le
président de la république l'ancien
maire de rambouillet a réaffirmé ses
réserves sur plusieurs points avancés
par le président et son souhait d'avoir
aussi un meilleur contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement dans le futur les
détails dorés liront les collectivités
territoriales ne sont pas un problème
mais une chance pour la france est
depuis plusieurs mois un groupe de
sénateurs planchent sur la réforme
constitutionnelle
un chantier d'envergure lancée par
emmanuel macron en juillet dernier
devant le congrès à versailles
entre le président français et le
président du sénat gérard larcher les
avis divergent sur plusieurs points
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats dans
le temps ou encore la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires
nous proposons de préserver l'ancrage
territorial des parlementaires en
prévoyant à l'article 24 de la
constitution l'élection au moins d'un
député ou d'un sénateur par département
vient s'ajouter
la question du cumul des mandats dans le
temps des élus locaux et des
parlementaires qui ne paraît pas
acceptable en l'état
pour une majorité du groupe de travail
pour le sénateur des yvelines et chef de
la chambre haute du parlement il faut
avant tout préserver le lien entre les
parlementaires et nos territoires
je vais prendre un exemple on y lit le
bretonneux avant-hier près de 1000
personnes
comment voulez vous que l'on dise temps
si la relation entre un parlementaire
des maires et les citoyens autre projet
qui tient à coeur gérard larcher la
ligne 18 du grand paris express
son avenir devrait être précisées dans
les prochains jours il n'y a pas de vrai
avenir solide pour le plateau de saclay
et donc aussi de versailles à
rambouillet pour toute cette partie là
si nous n'avons pas des moyens de
transport concernant le projet de loi de
révision de la constitution il devrait
être présenté fin février par le
gouvernement
l'abandon de la candidature candidature
française pour l'exposition universelle
de 2025 était aussi au coeur de
l'actualité locale cette semaine un
abandon qui impacte les départements des
yvelines et de l'essonne terre d'accueil
du village global et qui a fait réagir
le président de l'université paris
saclay il était sur notre plateau lundi
soir extraits pour nous c'était un gain
de notoriété énorme on est déjà une
université qui existe on y reviendra
c'est pas juste un projet mais avoir des
millions des dizaines de millions de
visiteurs qui auront été en contact avec
ce territoire qui auront vu les
bâtiments universitaires qui auront vu
des personnels des étudiants mobilisés
sur certaines activités de l'exposition
universelle ça aurait été un gain de
notoriété énorme au moment où on lance
cette cette université une centaine
d'acteurs des quartiers de la politique
de la ville étaient réunis mercredi à
versailles la préfecture des yvelines
organisé un séminaire thématique la
république dans les quartiers un temps
pour échanger autour du sujet et
améliorer la compréhension des valeurs
de la république et camille lambert a pu
suivre cette journée
reportage être français se sentir
français laïcité et citoyenneté des
notions parfois difficile à aborder pour
les habitants des quartiers en politique
de la ville représentants d'associations
élus et acteurs sociaux ont participé à
ce séminaire en préfecture des yvelines
objectif trouver des réponses concrètes
à des questions parfois abstraites
certains jeunes nous disent la
république nous a marqués dans les
grands ensembles république ne doit
maintenant s'adapter à nous quand on
prend l'histoire il n'y a pas de volonté
politique de parquets des gens dans ces
quartiers au contraire on fait face à la
construction la reconstruction après
guerre on revient sur des éléments
factuels pour se réapproprier vraiment
ce qu'il en est écoutez les acteurs de
terrain au contact des habitants les
orienter mais surtout échanger sur leur
ressenti et leurs projets comme celui de
l'association mosaïque des que vit elle
a réalisé un film avec les jeunes de son
quartier
ce projet là en fait que ce travail en
amont a récemment permis déjà de
découvrir - même s'il découvrait les
autres donc le vivre ensemble et le côté
humain qui est important surtout à
retenir
au quotidien on peut avoir des
questionnements autour de la laïcité
on a vu que c'est des choses qui font
débat au niveau de la société et le
ramène à leur échelle
nous notre travail c'est de permettre
voilà de leurs paramètres de parts d'en
parler librement des changes et une
journée qui répond au plan de
mobilisation nationale du gouvernement
sur la politique de la ville lancé en
novembre
le compte rendu de ce séminaire sera
adressée à jacques mézard ministre de la
cohésion des territoires
c'était il ya vingt ans le 23 janvier
1998 11 personnes dont 9 collégiens de
saint françois d'assise à montigny le
bretonneux mouraient dans une avalanche
aux orres dans les hautes-alpes
la catastrophe avait largement ému en
france vous le voyez sur ces images des
milliers de personnes étaient venues
assister aux obsèques au gymnase pierre
de coubertin transformait alors en
chanteur chaabi en chapelle ardente en
mémoire du drame mardi une messe de
recueillement a eu lieu au collège saint
françois d'assise ce sont trois lettres
que certaines villes redoute sru en
référence à la loi de l'an 2000 qui vise
à rééquilibrer le parc hlm sur le
territoire en france et qui impose un
taux minimum de logements sociaux dans
les zones les plus denses 19 villes des
yvelines sont pointés du doigt par
l'état pour leur manque d'efforts dans
le domaine et se voient pénalisés par la
préfecture les détails avec ce reportage
pas assez de logements sociaux aux
clayes-sous-bois alors c'est la
préfecture des yvelines qui reprend la
main
la loi est claire d'ici 2025 les villes
soumises aux dispositifs sru devront
avoir 25 % de logements sociaux
et si elle ne respecte pas le rythme de
construction les sanctions tombent
pénalités financières et droit de
préemption urbain pour l'état autrement
dit la préfecture récupère le contrôle
pour la réalisation de logements sociaux
une injustice pour la mère des
clayes-sous-bois et ne lui manque que 11
logements pour respecter le seuil des
25%
on a beaucoup un sentiment de colère et
d'injustice
face à la demie surtout face à
l'administration et à son regard sur la
réalité de ce que l'on vit ce que vivent
les maires dans les communes on est
traité un peu comme des gens qui ont
comment dire qu'ils mettent à font
preuve de mauvaise volonté mais c'est
pas du tout enfin c'est pas le cas dans
le département des yvelines 19 communes
sont particulièrement mis en cause pour
leurs manquements à la loi 79 ans tout
sur la région ile de france la loi sru
vise principalement à rééquilibrer sur
le territoire le parc hlm
un dispositif que la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux l 16 % de
logements sociaux soit très voir
appliquée à l'échelle de l'agglomération
quand la ville nouvelle a été créée par
son voisin était vu comme le quartier
résidentiel qui devait accueillir des
pavillons pourquoi fait on hérite d'une
histoire qu'on nous reproche aujourd'hui
et ce n'était pas un choix de l'époque
c'est l'état lui-même qui a fait le
choix de répartir différents quartiers
comme ça sur 50 en ligne un projet de
loi logement sera dévoilé au mois de
mars prochain le gouvernement pourrait
alors décider d'assouplir dans certains
cas la loi sru
il est en lice parmi les plus beaux de
france le marché notre dame à versailles
a été sélectionné pour un concours
organisé par le journal le parisien et
tf1 le lieu accueille tout au long de
l'année touristes et habitants du
quartier et des alentours
alors notre dame plus beaux marchés de
franz lehar et gémit quel ennemi d'euros
sont allés sur place poser la question
le marché notre dame est un lieu
incontournable pour la vie de la ville
de versailles
trois matinées par semaine le micro
village de la place du marché s'anime
fruits et légumes en tous genres fromage
viande ou encore plats préparés tout y
est
alors quand on demande aux visiteurs ce
qu'il pense du lieu parce que c'est le
plus beau
marché de france bah oui bien sûr parce
que c'est versailles ya du choix par
rapport à la province je pense que n'a
rien à envier aux marchés traditionnels
de progress les commerçants l'ambiance
les produits tout est bien il est très
charmant caractéristiques de cette place
13 convient aéré versailles notre dame
est le plus beau marché français le plus
accueillant
construit sous louis xiii le marché est
d'abord un lieu d'histoire
il s'étend dans d'anciennes halles et
sur une place un peu excentré du château
de versailles
les commerçants sont fiers de travailler
sur cet emplacement emblématique tresse
selon le marché oui pourquoi pas cette
diversité salvayre parce qu'on a à
versailles 1 c'est la ville des rois les
votes du concours qui ont le plus bon
marché de francs seront clôturées le 15
février prochain les 24 marchés encore
en lice auront la chance d'être mise à
l'honneur lors du journal de 13 heures
de jean pierre pernaut avant l'annoncé
officielle du vainqueur c'est la fin de
ce set 8 l'hebdo retour de l'actualité
en direct lundi à 18h sur l'antenne de
tv 78 bon week-end à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]